[Music]
trays jerry take that' the dutch cherry
torn
that is by sister kenny normal language
with an exception
bread take down have the people who
are dependent on a boat
some can get to
their destination by bike and otherwise
have to  walk happen
[Music]
I'm with the deputy mayor of
giethoorn well there are about 2400 inhabitants
and eleven hundred houses and boat
let a boat have a good day there are
already about 500 600 signs here we are
walking through this year become direction
towns was there in boatbuilders
choose punts sleep poor blue
ridge one the ingi thor will originate in
giethoorn
but one currently they are really going all over the
world making boats ter bridges through their
green sixtyseven public drop and so
jamie chung people each  groceries the
furniture care bring beer in which
giethoorn
the master edgar here the tower bridge
guard if the bridge keepers stop
then it is light and dead quiet
because busy day  about 300 boats for which
we take care of the opening
platform boat is the parbat is bart and
herk
my idea of the place where we with old n
t only that is now a villa
e here yes a lot spend many homes and p
rpetrator this for blessing of fire
kept out but also for that
the savior of as many drowning people
boats that are certain or you name it
in this Jan choose in charge of minus 10
internet freelancer to that wrath
everything went around and the master
pastures and are just accessible by boat
and  chasing
the cows on the boat we don't see that much in the
Netherlands anymore but that
happens to be see through her
for us it is actually normal
so the have a fight density drone
tastes a live tiles well
crap pack includes the dmv can be read m
wide red green ditto
by john
[Music]